[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I'm
taking Carolina area 47 we're going down
a massive 55 foot waterslide and I'm
taking AJ to a former Olympic bobsled
course where we'll see how fast we go
come join us on our adventures on this
episode of travel dares this is travel
dares the show where we do daring
activities all across Europe empowered
by my Mariette Vaughn boy found list
card
AJ where are we we are in Innsbruck
Austria Innsbruck is located in the
heart of the house and it's perfect for
anyone looking for an adventure and
speaking of an adventure are you ready
for your first clue I'm so ready I'm so
excited okay get ready to fly okay
flying over Austria how high are we
flying that's just enough to make you
nervous I'm like 100% sure that we're
gonna be jumping off of something I
think we might be bungee jumping well we
might be skydiving this slide is known
officiating people super high in the air
and I'm excited to see if Carolina can
stick the landing
Oh God Steve my heart is beating now now
stay right here where you're going
okay I'm so excited what do I need to
know so I just lie down on your back
cross arms and legs keep our attention
and when you in the air you go forward
with your upper body so you can land on
your feet ready to just like fly in the
air I am so excited
could we get up there already let's get
to the top
[Music]
that's pretty steep yeah so you pick up
speed down here and it curves you as
well right here absolutely okay I just
go okay
okay I'm just gonna do it he's gonna go
okay oh my gosh my body is still shaking
and my heart is beating like a thousand
beats a minute like this is it's so
scary you guys it's actually really
scary Caroline how did it feel flying
through the air it was so much fun it
was like so exhilarating I'm ready to do
it again let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
good job I would say good job good job
go talk to you the slave the Dare I'm
getting a page a dime is such a thrill
but I have a feeling yours is a little
bit more give me that clue
hold on tight hold on tight okay I hope
so because you're gonna have to
innsbruck is known as a destination for
all winter sports and it's one of the
only places where you can bobsled in the
summer a really big step it's gonna be
so fun so hold on all right
[Music]
this is the official bobsled track for
the Olympics built in 1964 it's the only
track in in Austria where guests can go
down in a bobsled with a professional
driver and about 100 kilometers per hour
I am super so they said it's gonna take
about a minute and five six seconds to
go down I think we should shoot for
under a minute I think under a minute
got it gold safety is first guys so
there's got to put on our what you call
them a sock hat [ __ ] hat here we go that
is the professional technical drag I
feel so professional I am so ready for
this I'm going to crush this dare I'm
gonna get my 5 stars
and I'm gonna have a great time doing it
[Music]
here we go here we go all right so smart
[Music]
it's work is one of the most beautiful
places I've ever visited yeah and it's
really packed with adventure it has such
an amazing view of the Alps hey Jay I
slipped and I slid down the river to the
water how did I do
Caroline you were so excited for the
Dare you went down the slide a million
times
you gave flips cannonballs spins and you
really made a splash with that dare so
for that I can't give you anything other
than a five star I love a good 5 stars I
was born to fly hey Jay you took
bobsledding like a champ I always knew
you were a competitive person and you
really really wanted to beat that
average time and we didn't quite get
there and for that you're gonna have to
get a silver you're getting a four out
of five I could take a four yeah I can
take it's so good still get a medal AJ
I'm having such an amazing time
traveling with you I'm having a great
time - thanks for showing me around
Europe well thanks for finding such
awesome dares Cheers
[Music]